[Music]
I never had McDonald's growing up we
just didn't really eat that I was kosher
for a long time I'm actually now a
holistic health coach I've heard nothing
but bad things I think it's gonna be
pretty good I'm hoping that I just at
least won't happen a gag reflex the Big
Mac there's a lot of bread on this I
could not even taste the meat all I
could taste was a sauce it's just a mess
I would describe it as a disappointment
it's really not bad as I was just gonna
take a bite but I guess like a breakfast
this whole thing everything was very
bland it's a lot sweeter than I thought
it would be kind of like a dessert just
slightly dirty a little bit more
experienced I'm really looking forward
to knowing what all the fuss is about
that's what they're known for right okay
it's kind of a street they're actually
really good it just tastes like the
greasy string of fried potato I know
that's exactly what a french fry is you
do a very good job with the fryer
they're they're better than my
expectations hope my parents never see
this
there weren't that many other cherries
to pop and I finally pop this
[Music]